so Elon Musk has spent a lot of his life
thinking about space and he's got the
world's biggest rocket company so we
asked him have you ever seen anything
out there that suggests alien life and
by the way how do you think life on this
planet is going
Elon Musk has been one of the rare
voices to raise the alarm about lower
birth rates he's doing something about
it personally he thinks the rest of us
should too here's this part of the
conversation
[Music]
people sometimes take the fact that like
we're here on Earth for granted you know
and that this Consciousness is just a
normal thing that happens but to the
best of my knowledge we see no evidence
of uh
conscious uh life anywhere uh anywhere
in the universe so it might be there
um you know physics of course sort of
the Fermi Paradox after Enrico film it
was amazing physicist uh asks a
fundamental question what are the aliens
yeah
um a lot of people ask me you know
um where are the aliens and I I think if
if anyone would know about aliens on
Earth it would probably be me I would
think yeah I'm like you know very
familiar with space stuff
um
and I've seen no evidence of aliens so I
would I would immediately tweet you know
tweet it out this is Split Second and be
like that'll be like well old time
probably a tough tweet of all time I
found one guys
Mr jackpot 8 billion likes you know
um Next Level jackpot if you find that
aliens like I don't think they're
keeping this under you know and it was
like some um uh General I think in the
60s who who say like show us the aliens
like error 51 Etc and he said like
listen we're constantly trying to get
the defense budget to uh expand and uh
look you know what we really get uh no
arguments for anyone uh if we pull out
an alien
and said we need money to protect
ourselves from these guys
you know how much money do you want you
got it
they look dangerous
[Laughter]
the fastest way to get a defense budget
increase would you agree to pull out an
alien you know
we were like yeah I mean it could be the
invasion feed it could be arriving any
minute who knows
so
um
you know as I digress but but you were
saying that our Consciousness makes us
unique in the universe so far as we know
and that yes I'm not saying that we are
unique I'm simply stating to the best of
my knowledge that there is no evidence
for other uh conscious life I I I I hope
that there is and I hope they're
peaceful uh obviously the two important
characteristics um but um we're just
saying we haven't seen anything yet so
um but you think that we take our
existence here for granted yeah I think
there are threats to it yeah yeah yeah
exactly so
um
I I just think we should not assume that
Civilization is robust
um and if you if you look at the history
of civilizations the rise and fall of
the ancient Egyptians the ancient
Sumerians
um Rome you know this uh
throughout the world have been rising
full of many civilizations
um so there's an arc there's sort of a
live a sort of a life cycle Arc to to
civilizations just as there is to to
individual humans yes and
um
and I think we just want to make sure
that that you know uh we we have
civilization go onward and upward
um and uh that's for example why I'm
concerned about decreasing both rates
and and um the fact that for example
Japan uh had twice as many deaths last
year as births
so the the that's it and they're they're
a leading indicators this is can I say
and you've you've written and talked a
lot about this but can I just ask you to
pause just for a parenthetical note why
is that I mean the urge to have sex and
to procreate is after breathing and
eating the most basic urge how has it
been subverted
well it's just that in the past we could
rely upon
um you know simple uh limbic system
rewards uh in order to procreate um but
once you have birth control
um and you know uh abortions and whatnot
now now you now you can still satisfy
Olympic Instinct but not appropriate
um so we didn't we haven't yet evolved
to
deal with that because this is all
fairly recent in the last 50 years or so
um before birth control yes I'm sort of
worried that hey civilization you know
don't if we don't make enough people to
at least sustain our numbers perhaps
increase a little bit then civilization
is going to crumble just the old
question of like uh will civilization
end with a bang or a whimper well it's
currently trying to end with a whimper
in adult diapers yes uh which is
depressing as hell
the most depressing I mean seriously
yeah war is less depressing yeah it's
really the guy with a bang yeah your
shoes on yeah not with your exciting
yeah
[Music]
whatever you think of Elon Musk he's one
of the rare figures in this country
maybe around the world who sticks to the
fundamentals how do we keep the human
race going what's good for Humanity and
what's bad those are the questions our
leaders should be discussing instead
they're lecturing us about trans rights
and systemic racism so it's refreshing
to hear if you'd like to hear the entire
thing the full uninterrupted interview
every minute our cameras were on with
Elon Musk that's coming soon it's going
up on Fox Nation tomorrow morning we
highly recommend it
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight